as a lot of teams do mark was the length
of the Lakers but JaVale McGee gotten
that passing lane and is like right
there their size inside it's going to be
problematic for this Miami team to me on
both ends and LeBron James with the miss
Davis with the follow he's coming off
the bench this year but other guys
certainly would factor into that
starting lineup up top in a punch by ad
right to the jaw James and Davis those
two teaming up for the second time in a
row after missing 11 games with an
injury Davis option number one and
that's a good option watch Anthony work
on the post he's gonna square him up he
thinking okay come on
York Los Angeles in the middle of a long
road trip after this they'll go to
Atlanta then Indiana followed by
Milwaukee LeBron and one fouled by
Derrick Jones jr. points on the boards
then he has turnovers he had seven now
that's his eighth point it's been a
little bit of a struggle here what do
you make of his turnovers Doris is it
the heat disease that's constantly
working on Linux from D James with the
board and a quick hit ahead to Davis
they do that repeatedly and that's often
the results touchdown ad then how close
the Miami defensive player is and yet
the only guy who can't catch it is
Anthony Davis they do that at least a
couple times a game correct that is one
heck of an outlet pass body fat of each
player and LeBron James is going to get
the and
and there's going to be a dent in Kelly
olynyk's chest high in this move that's
a walk he was moving that's absolutely a
block a man no sometimes it's the angle
at which you see it but Timmy's not said
Leonard a proficient three ball shooter
but not that time at a pile but watch
five JaVale McGee Lakers lead the league
in blocked shots LeBron with the globe
on and I talking about the five threes
he wants an attempted four game
obviously full of intensity Ben playoff
flight very much
LeBron for the Thai border 65 apiece and
LeBron James looks at his bench and says
I know the rims here spacing becomes
different hat how do you guard them you
can put them on virtually every spot of
the floor and the game fall dorasan one
stir is island again LeBron James just a
pinpoint paths easy opportunity for his
teammate how about LeBron James
McKenna's owned by the Miami Heat
Jane's 83 got it seven on the shot clock
for a team
Silva right with them good contest but a
better offensive play by Anthony Davis
West 25 now bill by Rondo and Bradley on
that sequence to force the turnover up
by the heat James with a three and
that's the way you want to start the
fourth quarter here the Lakers Jones
guarding James nine on the shot clock
great cross-court bind by LeBron and
Dudley has his first three
now setting up shop
[Music]
great pass to pull up my cutter
- vision is ridiculous
Butler on James
off to Davis screen downhill and LeBron
put a minute wait room Oh James with a
great tab Daisy
and James is working how does he know to
touch pass that to Anthony Davis down
there Ronis dangers playing from the
elbow out to 18 compete got it butter
the big badge is another one what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content